[Música]
es que ayer domingo 14 de noviembre se
celebraron las elecciones legislativas
en argentina donde la oposición liderada
por afines al ex presidente mauricio
macri logró consolidar una mayoría en
los escaños del congreso esta es una
segunda derrota electoral consecutiva
para el oficialismo peronista de alberto
fernández que ya fracasó en las
primarias hace dos meses reflejando así
un deterioro en su popularidad vinculado
con la inflación y la pobreza que
atraviesa este país sudamericano para
ello quiero saludar en este momento a
nuestro primer analista de hoy sergio
berenstein analista político y también
presidente y director general de bahrein
gracias a sergio por estar con nosotros
en directo américa de francés 24 por
supuesto empecemos con una mirada
general que lectura después le podemos
dar entonces a estas elecciones y cómo
queda ahora el gobierno de fernández
la sociedad argentina votó ayer de forma
muy contundente el oficialismo del
frente de todos perdidos casi un tercio
de su volumen electoral comparado con
elección de
octubre del año 2019 de 48 por ciento a
33 con 15 puntos es muy significativa la
caída que ha sufrido el peronismo la
oposición con el contrario
logra un resultado electoral muy
positivo por tercera vez consecutiva
sube de 40 por ciento de los votos es
muy regular la oposición la argentina se
establece ahora como un sistema de dos
grandes coaliciones que le da
estabilidad del sistema político son
coaliciones de heterogéneas que tienen
disputas por el liderazgo pero que a
diferencia de lo que ocurre en otros
países de la región
no hemos sufrido una fragmentación del
arco político
entonces esto creo que es un dato
importante de cada el futuro el congreso
ha quedado muy muy muy equilibrado en la
cámara diputados hay una diferencia
apenas dos representantes a favor del
frente de todos tienen senado el
peronismo ha perdido su quórum que fue
algo tradicional en 38 años de
democracia por primera vez va a estar
obligado a negociar con senadores
independientes y con posición lo cual
implica un cambio muy significativo en
el equilibrio de poderes en la
democracia argentina eso le quería
preguntar sergio entonces cómo queda la
gobernabilidad dentro del legislativo
del presidente fernández qué tan difícil
lo tiene o si realmente puede buscar
entonces esa coalición es fácilmente
para poder aprobar las leyes
recordemos que la argentina tiene un
sistema muy presidencialista parecido al
de la cuarta república francesa
hiperpresidencialista con lo cual lo
primero que hay que mirar aquí es el
equilibrio interno dentro de la colisión
frente de todos es muy heterogéneo los
sectores más duros más radicalizados que
están identificados con la figura de la
vicepresidente espira fernández de
kirchner file en la distancia ideológica
conceptual comitiva muy significativa
respecto a los sectores más moderados
del peronismo
entonces el primer elemento para
dilucidar en términos de gobernabilidad
justamente pasa por el equilibrio
interno en la coalición gobernante hay
riesgos de ruptura bueno hasta ahora los
sectores más radicalizados hay una
agrupación llamada la cámpora donde
lidera el hijo de la vicepresidenta
máximo cristal también diputado que
ellos hasta ayer se oponían a un acuerdo
con el fondo monetario internacional el
presidente en un discurso grabado
ayer anticipó iba a enviar al parlamento
a comienzos de diciembre un paquete en
eses vinculados precisamente a este
eventual acuerdo con el fondo así se
abre una duda de si el presidente va a
lograr disciplinar a todos los sectores
internos de su coalición o si va a haber
una fragmentación de la coalición
gobernante esto lo debilitaría mucho más
y al mismo tiempo los sectores
tradicionales del peronismo que han
salido relativamente fortalecidos ayer
gobernadores del norte del noroeste
intendentes del gran buenos aires son
sectores muy pragmáticos y
biológicamente más moderados que podrían
darle al presidente un apoyo
compensatorio que rompe con los sectores
más radicalizados esa es la cuestión que
la ve mirando la gobernabilidad la
oposición de juntos por el cambio no es
obstruccionista es una oposición
ideológicamente muy distinta pero que no
va a generar dificultades en términos
del presupuesto
de otras medidas como para que el
gobierno no pueda avanzar en una agenda
de gobernabilidad sobre todo tiene en
cuenta la situación económica que es muy
muy compleja eso y le quería le quería
preguntar por eso que tan necesaria y
como el presidente alberto fernández
entonces debe afrontar esta
renegociación de la deuda con el fondo
monetario internacional digamos que esto
pudo ser una una piedra en el zapato un
punto a favor para los resultados que
vemos el día de ayer en contra perdón
la elección no tuvo relación con la
deuda con el fondo la lección se explica
fundamentalmente por un proceso de
estancamiento con alta inflación llamada
de estanflación que la argentina sufre
ya hace más de una década sin creación
de empleo con un deterioro notable del
ingreso de la población también
obviamente hubo un desgaste extra en
ario por la 40 inés trick implementada
por el gobierno en el contexto de la
pandemia de kobe 19 y muchos escándalos
errores no forzados del gobierno que han
debilitado enormemente la autoridad
presidencial algunos de ellos vinculados
con la presencia de carácter la
fortaleza de la vicepresidenta cristina
fernández kirchner alberto fernández es
un presidente legítimo pero que carece
de peso político propio nunca fue un
líder relevante en la política argentina
carece de peso territorial y su
prestigio fue erosionado por muchos
errores en la gestión en la comunicación
incluyendo algunos escándalos no menores
como por ejemplo celebrar el cumpleaños
de la pareja del presidente la quinta de
oliva se emplea 40 estricta eso ha
debilitado mucho la palabra presidencial
hay otro elemento que explica la
elección de ayer es el incremento en la
criminalidad
la argentina vive en la ola de
inseguridad muy violenta con el aumento
del crimen es en todo el territorio pero
sobre todos los grandes centros urbanos
y el gobierno ha tenido una postura
bastante pasiva frente a los reclamos de
mejora en la seguridad pública entonces
en la cuestión del fondo es mirando al
futuro de argentina en una deuda muy
importante con el fondo es un préstamo
que pidió el gobierno del presidente
mauricio macri en el año 2018 es una
deuda de aproximadamente 44 mil millones
de dólares y hay un vencimiento el año
próximo en marzo para el cual argentina
no tiene recursos con lo cual hay tiempo
hasta marzo para llegar a un acuerdo con
la institución de lo contrario
entraríamos en default no solamente con
el fondo monetario también con de las
instituciones financieras incluyendo de
parís pues sergio muchísimas gracias
entonces por este análisis por entender
un poco la compleja situación que vive
argentina en ese momento luego de estas
elecciones legislativas